hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wir heute 25 mio ich hätte
heute instagram bilder nach harry hat
vor einer woche video hochgeladen wo sie
auch instagram bilder nachgestellt hatte
das haben wir schon die räder und alle
anderen gemacht deswegen habe ich
deswegen habe ich mir vor allem auch
gedacht dass das erste bild dieses bild
hier von kelly sein wird was ich jetzt
versuche nachzustellen sie macht doch
irgendwie so eine komische posen mit der
hand und einer hand so komisch die
andere hand hinter dem rücken hinterfuß
schräg seitlich ein bisschen deutlicher
seitlicher das pokerface der kurator
gut gut was los wäre es dass hier von
kylie jenner wo die ich muss mich
hinsetzen dafür jede bank sie hat eine
hand hin zum abstützen kann beine sind
schon sind schon sehr gut
dann brauchst du jetzt brüste zu
erhöhten den kopf zu anderen rechte
schulter guckst du bist sexy morgen auf
dem boden
vor dem nächsten
bild sag ich jetzt mal hände so hinterm
rücken und dessen so auf der hälfte
drauf hast du so ausgeschnitten cook war
jukic körbel das nächste fotos miley
cyrus ich bin euch das jetzt mal kurz
ein die sache ist die hat er quasi
selber die kamera in der hand ein paar
sekunden später ja die anderen titel im
rücken so dass man die schultern ein
bisschen pressebild ist dieses bild hier
von einer gewissen anderen youtube
die beauty palast dafür bräuchten
eigentlich eine dusche haben wir gerade
nicht aber wir haben so ein kumpel da
vorne damit kann das eigentlich machen
hedgefonds man mit einer hand
nein beide hände hinten hinter es waren
gerade von uns so dass man steht hinter
dass man gerade ist so gerade erst ihr
baby kurz zu machen
lach lach noch wie als wäre ich verrückt
nicht wahr
wir sind photoshop passt das auf das
hintere bein gerade das hintere gesagt
er ist bei dem nächsten bild brauche ich
eine zweite person deswegen jetzt alles
glaubt ein
das bild ist dieses bild hier von tiger
wie er auf einem stuhl sitzt und lacht
und dort nach bisschen enger die beine
ganz nah zusammen fasste seine
kniescheiben genau ganz leicht nach
rechts und reißt den mund auf ist das
gut für das nächste bild braucht schon
wieder eine andere person und zwar 32
das nächste bild ist dieses bild hier
von teddy teclebrhan lkw kam total
sundance kid mauerwerk zusammen war
schon da aber die eltern wissen weiter
vor und bisschen nach unten
ja das passt aber ich würde vielleicht
noch t shirt in die hose steckt the last
picture dies von seinem instagram model
aus deutschland
jimmy choo choo
aber dahinter so in seine haarpracht
offenbacher geht nicht geläutet und
jetzt alle screen schatten und die app
instagram rock linken seit 21 22 25 5000
ja aber das ist jetzt halt gerade das
war es jetzt hier vom video meine damen
und herren im hintergrund steht ein paar
kinder eingeblendet haben wir eine
seilbahn geklaut wenn es euch gefallen
hat würde ich mich über eine bewertung
freund schreiten meine kommentare von
welcher person nicht am besten nach
gemacht habe also schreibt die sowas wie
justin bieber oder kylie jenner oder
irgendwas in die kommentare wenn ihr
findet okay von der person habe ich am
besten gemacht findet kellys video in
der beschreibung auch verlinkt das ganze
ja ein bisschen von ihr kommt die idee
deswegen also bleibe ich stehen tschüss